[Music]
ariana grande's new music video is a
stunning visual a pop made me feel kind
of poor but it's riddled with easter
eggs as she likes to do so today we're
gonna break down some of the details you
might have missed in seven rings that
little tune at the beginning of the song
is the exact same as the intro from the
thank you next video one time on twitter
i heard ariana was pregnant so i got
pregnant so we could be pregnant at the
same time turns out it was just a rumor
so not only has she been teasing the
sound since that music video dropped in
November she's been captioning Instagram
photos with the lyrics to seven rings
since October she references her
gloriously iconic ponytail and
extensions saying
gee thanks speaking of sound the sound
of music makes a little cameo with our
ease bujji sampling of my favorite
things and bottles of girls in white
dresses with blue satin sashes
snowflakes that stay on my nose and
eyelashes silver white winters that melt
into Springs these are a few of my
favorites some pops off about Rich's
champagne spending money and guess what
it's a true story
it's no secret Ariana had some tough
days last year and on Twitter she said
she had a particularly rough day so she
took her squad to Tiffany's had too much
champagne and bought herself and six of
her friends rings they thought it was so
insane and funny that they ended up
writing a song about it
that afternoon Ariana's mom and Nonna
also got rings making it a total of nine
but they received theirs after the song
was written her seven rings squad all
appear in the music video but they're
not the only special cameos Ari's dog
Toulouse makes an unplanned appearance
miss Elise
all right hi Toulouse Christie be a
trained dog no you just get sick
re-tweeted t wasn't originally supposed
to be in this video but he literally
wouldn't leave me set the shot so what a
king who knows his angles what was your
favorite look or a moment from the video
did you notice any other references we
want to hear more about it so I'm a -
Crossin and until next time we've got
you covered
[Music]